you talked about this with the team
a lot of things that you want to
accomplish we talked about winning the
division we talked about getting the
first round by winning a playoff game to
get into the conference championship
winning the conference championship to
get to the super bowl we've been
checking things off and make no mistake
about it got a lot of respect for the
patriots but we're going there to get
this last check
looking like jumpsuit january at uh the
ram sendoff
cat would love would love that reference
the rams outside their new stadium a
good crowd yeah not quite the 35 000
that showed up in foxborough but rams
fans there the rams ready to go and sean
mcvay may be getting sleep or maybe not
getting sleep this week peter king joins
us for the full hour and peter
fascinating football morning in america
you can read it now at
profootballtalk.com but don't read it
right now listen to what peter has to
say and then you can read it pretty good
at your job man
in the car early early how did that all
come to be and why in the world did it
happen as early as it did on saturday
morning well last week right about this
time i i texted um
artist twyman the pr guy in the room
said i'd love to do this with sean mcvay
i did it last year with doug peterson
i've done things like this before super
bowls
and a couple of days went by and so
finally i just i also texted sean
mcvay
and i said i told him what i wanted to
do friday or saturday morning early
let's get in the car i'll ride with you
well he texted me back right away he
said yeah sure i'll do it
and so uh
i arranged it with him uh and uh i was
at his house at 3 30 saturday morning in
the hills north of la he said 4 15 but
i've heard funny stories about him in
time right and so he walks out of his uh
this house at 10 after four coughlin
time or as i said insane standard time
yeah insane and uh we got in the car and
we drove but here's the interesting
thing that i found in this whole thing
that not only is he
uh ready to go at 4 10. but he's ready
to go with applicable good
interesting fun correct stories for the
moment like
belichick has texted him after every win
this year wow and belichick he got to
know belichick last year really well at
the combine they spent some time
together and then remember i also wrote
this in my column
that uh you remember they trade for
brandon cooks last year
and
he and belichick were the ones who got
this done you know it was not done let's
need nick casario you know gm to gm or
or president it wasn't done that way it
was basically done
with
uh between mcveigh and belichick and
mcvay thought he had a deal done
for uh
you know basically brandon cooks in a
four for that one and belichick in the
course of their conversation ended up
getting a six back
and so you know mcvay wanted the guy so
bad that he didn't i mean he they must
have negotiated but originally they
weren't gonna give the six and then they
gave the six
so he also he knows how to compete with
belichick and he'll be uh it'll be an
interesting week for him here i honestly
think that's like one of the underlying
things i look at in the match up because
like i look at a lot of times in new
england you've heard me say this before
where i just go
the one thing that gets lost with
competing against new england is you
have to compete against their coaches
and you know belichick is going to be in
the office all day with his staff and i
mean it sounds like and you probably
know more than this but it sounds like
mcveigh is like that kind of guy that is
there all day long he lives it he's got
no family to go home to
chris you will you will understand this
perfectly now do you remember the super
bowl last year where i ended up writing
about this after the game
that the winning touchdown in the super
bowl yes nick foles 11 yards to zach
ertz they were in a one by four
formation
one of the very rare times all year that
philadelphia ran this formation right
they never ran the motion they ran with
it in that formation and they didn't
have zach ertz as the one on the left so
the patriots had never seen this before
right and when i started to tell that
story mcveigh goes oh yeah the one by
four yeah
mcveigh has seen this play he studied
this play and and and what i believe he
didn't say this so this is just me peter
king divining this after being with him
and after watching the super bowl last
year where the philadelphia eagles the
way that they beat the new england
patriots is by running plays that in
history never in doug peterson's history
never in
frank reichsen nobody that they ever ran
these before and so that is what i
believe
we're going to see things maybe on both
sides too but we're going to see things
from the los angeles rams where it'll
come out after the game that they never
ran that in any way before and mcveigh
never ran it in his three years as
washington's offensive side shout
thyself are these things that mcveigh's
been holding in his pocket or are these
places he's going to come up with out of
the blue this week because last year
remember remember last year doug
peterson went to the super bowl last
year with a 192 play game plan they
landed minnesota he has a meeting with
his coaches and he says hey the hay is
not in the barn right i want you guys to
keep working and see if you can find
plays that can knock some of these 192
out of the game plan yeah sure and mike
grow the receiver's coach and frank
wright combined to find this play
that they saw um you know a combination
of which on other teams film yeah and
that's mike
what makes it so i don't want to say
easy but what makes it so different
right now today this year
is pro football focus uh and and really
good analytics people can can take plays
that might have been run
three years ago by alabama yeah right or
oklahoma state and they'll see things
because they have these things
programmed show me everything in ncaa
division one football with one by four
formations and jet sweep motion yeah
show yeah and they can they can feel it
so now wake forest against maryland in
2015. here it comes oh my god why can't
we do that right see that is what is
different about football right now
it is not hard to find to find
einstein's stuff
just simply by a click of the mouse yeah
all right i got a question for you i
mean you're you're a hall of famer
you're a legend like it's you're gonna
put on a gold jacket one day but this is
where you've been around a lot yeah i'm
putting you there but this is where i
want to ask you this with mcveigh you've
been around so many good coaches i want
to know
what does how does he stack up against
coaches you have seen through the years
and how does he stack up to a young
belichick when he was younger like if
you can remember that far long ago well
consider this bill belichick was 34
years old when he was the defensive
coordinator who frustrated john elway in
the super bowl
where your dad was 22 with 25. so he was
34 years old that day and that is when
bill belichick's star really began to
rise yeah sean mcveigh is 33 years old
he's going to try to find a game plan
this time that's going to make uh the
genius uncomfortable and see things that
he hasn't seen before
the the only thing and so i think i
think his legacy is i i a bunch of
people said well there's a legacy week
for sean mcvay he's got to do this i
mean sean mcvay's coach in another 25
years right he doesn't build his legacy
this week he could lose by 20 points and
people will say man he won the nfc
championship with a tiny bit of an
asteroid 32 years old yeah 32 years old
so
excuse me but my whole thing about this
my whole thing about this
sort of match-up in this game
is that
i think that belichick with two weeks
versus boy wonder with two weeks
i i think some somebody's head is gonna
explode on super bowl sunday night what
do you think belichick tries to take
away from the
la offense because that's always the
book on belichick find what they do best
and take it away is it gurley dante
hightower may i let it slip the other
day because he said he's expecting heavy
doses of gurley which tells me maybe
belichick's already telling them we're
going to game plan to stop gurley
he's kind of is he banged up is he in a
fight we don't know that we don't know
that i'll tell you this
i don't think there is one of the
strengths of this offense
is that they don't have a tyreek hill
and i don't mean that and everybody
would want to tire kill he's
unbelievable
but they were able to take away tyree
kill but i would just say this like
if you say well jeez they could take
away brandon cooks and i'm sure they
could if they wanted to right but robert
woods it's the same kind of guy offense
yeah is just as important right and so
you take away you take away one of those
guys i you know i
mike i don't think there is a guy
because honestly a big physical running
back behind a physical offensive line
like the rams have right you know and cj
anderson i'm not saying it can't work
but what i'm saying is that the patriots
have figured out
ways to stop a single person i think
that's a pretty multi-dimensional offer
i totally agree you're right i mean your
woods cook's point is like they're
interchangeable you can't peg one of
them as oh this is the deep guy or this
is the speed guy whatever it is i think
it's going to be down in the like the
inside zone like when we show their
running ability it's the number three
running team in football and you talked
about it i mean belichick's old school i
think he's going to look at and go all
the success golf woods cooks have it's
off of play action and what they do with
gurley and i really think they're gonna
pack the middle with three big guys and
play like that bear defense and cover
the center and two guards and then go
okay we got big people here now we can
devote some people to the bootlegs the
screens and the play-action paths at
least that's mine it could be a boring
super bowl it could be heavy running
from the rams and that power running
game yeah
i know this results yeah i mean at a
time when we had the 54-51 back in
november it could be you know 17-14 i
think it's i think it's a game in the
30s
because look didn't you know when you
were right near half-time of the afc
championship game didn't that look like
a 20 to 13 game and i mean look i'm not
saying that jared goff is mahomes but i
got to tell you something i've been
phenomenally impressed with jared goff
i mean look and and and i and mcveigh
told me a story for this column today
you've got to read the story that
basically jared goff talked sean mcvay
into running probably the best pass he
threw in this game it was the it was an
out route to bring into the left
sideline to the left sideline right and
that that out route was supposed to be
there was a bunch formation on the right
three receivers and cooks was alone on
the left and he was supposed to come
into the middle and mcvay figured
there's going to be so much traffic in
there that one of these four guys is
going to be open right but he said wait
a second i don't want to throw it into a
layered coverage yeah meaning aj klein
was going to be between him and marshawn
lattimore right he didn't want to throw
it over aj klein
in front of latimer he said if we go to
the outside klein's not going to follow
him there to double them yeah it'll just
simply be single latimore on cooks and i
think i can win that right and mcveigh
said to me said hey
that's not what i would have called but
he really wanted it so i audibled to it
on that play
and goff changed the play at the line in
that immense
thunder dome right and he changed the
play and he made a perfect throw and
that really started them going on
offense all i'm saying is that goff's
been really impressive in the postseason
after maybe a month ago when he had that
crisis sure of of the bears and the rams
and even against the lions that detroit
he didn't play well but i i'm i think i
think golf you've got to hand it to golf
he's really good yeah i mean that's how
you become a franchise quarterback you
have big performances and big moments
and this is his ultimate opportunity
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports